who do y'all think is the biggest winner
and katie's the first option is kevin i
honestly could probably see him at
number three i like number three because
he's in between yeah
cuz i don't think he's a loser who's the
option number two for us steve nash has
to be one of these people i think steve
nash is towards the bottom because
he can still get fired a month into the
season if they stuff you can put steven
asked that five team national five
school the next guy is gonna be kyrie
irving how he's gotta be one of the top
shows he gets to still play with his
homie kevin durant even over ben i think
ben simmons would have been higher than
kyrie irving kyrie and ben have to be
one and two one yeah we're going to put
western conference that's four number
one i would say ben but you're gonna be
able to come back to the floor and have
kevin durant kyrie on that court with
him in one tattoo and then four we said
western conference if i knew where's the
conference it's gonna be on that would
have been fine yeah